mesdames messieurs bon dimanche la lutte
au changement climatique ne semblait pas
au centre des préoccupations du premier
mandat du gouvernement logo mais le vent
serait-il en train de tourner dans son
discours d'ouverture mercredi le Premier
ministre a abondamment parlé des
occasions d'affaires qu'une économie
verte pouvait signifier pour le Québec
de l'importance aussi de construire de
nouveaux barrages pour électrifier la
province et éliminer pour de bons les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
qu'est-ce que cela signifie pour le
ministre de l'Environnement de la lutte
au changement climatique la faune les
départs je pose la question à Benoît
Charette mais d'abord le résumé des
ambitions de François Legault
actuellement le Québec émet 50% moins de
GS par habitant que le reste l'Amérique
du Nord donc on est déjà un leader puis
je veux qu'on aille plus loin plus vite
pour réduire nos GS mais je veux aussi
qu'on coordonne ça avec l'illumination
de notre écart de richesse en devenant
un leader de l'économie verte donc c'est
un chantier qui est gigantesque
bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
le Premier ministre dans son discours
d'ouverture indiqué qu'il voyait
clairement un avantage économique à
prendre un virage vert et il dit qu'il
veut voir des résultats rapidement votre
objectif pour le deuxième mandat quel
est-il possible importantes à respecter
en fait le Québec par le passé
malheureusement ne pas réussir à
atteindre ces cibles en matière de
réduction GLS pour 2030 37.5% de
réduction par rapport à l'année de 1990
donc c'est majeur ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire qu'il faut renforcer notre
démarche ce que l'on devrait confirmer
l'hôtel printemps prochain vous êtes
déjà en retard sur les sur les
réductions anti vous faites ça comment
réussir à rattraper sur terre là dans un
très court laps de temps dans les
prochaines semaines on va dévoiler les
résultats de l'année 2020 il faut savoir
qu'au niveau des réductions de GES le
bilan arrive toujours de deux années
plus tard le temps de comptabiliser
justement les émissions de chacune des
sources de démission donc en décembre
mi-décembre on devrait avoir un portrait
déjà relativement plus précis mais je
vous le cacherai pas alors on a un gros
défi on a une côte assez abrupte à
monter son vinte de la cible de 2030
mais en même temps faut être positif
lorsqu'on est lancé le plan pour une
économie verte il y a un petit peu plus
de deux ans on avait identifié
42% du travail à réaliser on avait du
financement pour ces mesures là l'année
dernière au niveau de la mise à jour on
était rendu à
51%. donc l'objectif c'est d'augmenter
et d'ajouter des pourcentages chaque
année pour être à 100%. vous dites quoi
québécois est-ce que vous commencez à
dire au Québécois il va y être des choix
qui vont devoir être faits il y a des
comportements qui vont devoir changer on
a adopté dans le dernier mandat des
gestes de rupture important on est un
des premiers états d'avoir à travers une
loi adoptée la fin de la vente de
véhicule neuf à essence cet effet il y a
un petit peu plus d'une année 2035 dans
le cas du Québec et cette année elle est
importante 2035 parce qu'après nous il y
a l'Union européenne qui s'est collé
exactement sur le calendrier qu'on avait
nous-même identifié la Californie il y a
quelques semaines tout juste qu'il y a
d'opté une législation semblable donc ce
sont des gestes de rupture on en a
adopté d'autres au niveau des autobus
scolaires dorénavant les sociétés de
transport scolaire s'ils veulent
bénéficier du financement public et
devront se doter de nouveaux véhicules
100% électrique la même chose pour les
sociétés de transport urbains donc oui
ça commande des changements de
comportement tant au niveau des
individus qu'au niveau de nos
partenaires autant organisationnels que
de la société ça ce sont des mesures que
vous avez déjà évoquées que vous avez
déjà annoncé ce qu'il y en aura d'autres
est-ce que il y a est-ce que il doit y
en avoir d'autres pour atteindre les
objectifs oui bah en fait je vous
parlais de la fin des années afin de la
vendre des véhicules à essence pour
l'année 2035
on va devoir resserrer la norme 0
émissions c'est un règlement que le
Québec doit être dicté là normalement
dans les prochains mois donc il y aura
des obligations notamment pour les
constructeurs de rendre disponible
davantage de véhicules électriques dans
des délais raisonnables parce qu'on le
sait pour certains modèles actuellement
on peut attendre une année sinon deux
donc la personne qui planifie son achat
elle peut penser à un véhicule
électrique mais une personne qui
malheureusement par exemple un accident
la voiture est perte totale doit la
remplacer du jour au lendemain c'est là
où elle a très peu de chance de trouver
aussi rapidement un véhicule qui soit
qui soit électrique donc il va y avoir
davantage de contraintes pour les
constructeurs sous peine de pénalité
sous peine d'amende donc il y a des
objectifs auxquels doivent se coller les
grands constructeurs on a beaucoup parlé
durant la campagne d'une potentiel de
Québec solidaire parlait d'une taxe sur
les véhicules plus polluant le ministre
terre de l'énergie a mené des études sur
l'impact que pour avoir une taxe comme
celle-là est-ce que c'est une voix qui
va devoir être étudiée plus sérieusement
d'après vous comme le proposait Québec
solder c'est une fausse bonne idée je
vous explique pourquoi Québec solidaire
proposait de pénaliser le choix des
automobilistes en partant à mon sens ce
n'est pas une bonne idée parce qu'on a
chacun des contraintes on a chacun nos
réalités ne serait-ce qu'à travers les
régions que l'on habite au Québec mais
doublement mauvaise idée c'est que
souvent l'alternative n'est pas
disponible donc pénaliser quelqu'un qui
achète un véhicule à essence parce que
son équivalent électrique n'est pas
disponible c'est pour moi contre eux il
y en a une formule qui pourrait être
applicable selon vous éventuellement
dans les prochaines années on va avoir
un défi à partir du moment où on a plus
de véhicules électriques sur nos routes
ce que ça veut dire c'est moins de
revenus de la taxe à essence et c'est
revenu là serve à financer l'entretien
de nos routes servent à financer nos
transports collectif donc c'est un défi
qu'il faut anticiper il y a déjà
réductions qui sont allés vers le pH sur
certaines routes est-ce que ça ça
pourrait être une option il y a rien
actuellement là qui est qui est arrêté
c'est un scénario qui devrait être
précisé lorsqu'un certain nombre
d'années je le disais la fin de la vente
des véhicules à essence pour 2035 les
revenus vont continuer à descendre entre
temps donc ce des réflexions qui peut
qui pourront avoir lieu très
certainement différents ministères mais
jamais on ne pénalisera un contribuable
une contribuable si l'alternative
n'existe pas je vais pas vous entendre
sur la COP15 qui commence mercredi à
Montréal le Québec fait me montrer du
doigt comme un mauvais élève
au chapitre de la protection des espèces
menacées le comité désigné pour pour
s'occuper de ce dossier là pour été
consulté par votre gouvernement puissant
quoi comme message je peux vous parler
d'une statistique qui m'inquiétait
encore davantage le gouvernement n'a pas
mis sa liste d'espèces menacées
vulnérables à jour depuis 2009 donc ça
fait plusieurs plusieurs années sans
tout vous révéler à ce moment-ci je peux
vous confirmer qu'il y aura de belles
annonces dans le cadre de la Coop 15 à
ce sujet-là mais au niveau de la
protection du patrimoine naturel à
l'échelle internationale Québec fait
office de leader littéralement on avait
une cible à atteindre pour 2020 20 au
niveau des heures protégées et on est un
des rares à voir réussi à protéger 17%
de notre territoire il y a un cadre
mondial normalement qui devrait être
négocié à travers cette Cope là on va
souhaiter qu'une entente internationale
intervienne mais peu importe les Suisses
je pense que c'est le mot que je peux
réitérer peu importe l'issue de la
négociation internationale le Québec au
cours des prochains jours des deux
prochaines semaines prendra des
engagements importants qui confirmera
que le Québec continue d'exercer un
leadership très très fort sur ces
enjeux-là
de la lutte contre les changements
climatiques de la faune et des parcs
merci d'avoir été des nôtres un plaisir
une belle fin de journée vous